[Music]
we hear the Scoobies laugh but there's
no Scooby which leads me to believe this
was a haunting image for some younger
children that assumed scooby-doo might
be brewed also AOL great I was just in
the middle of writing a hilarious joke
about this updated theme song being sung
by what had to have been Smash Mouth and
Shaggy interrupts it also using Shaggy
the musician for your theme song isn't
that a little on the nose expositional
scary pics or it didn't happen also
trust me folks time to settle in for a
long stretch of butt fartin poop jokes
that would make the Garbage Pail Kids
groan when the lunar ghost rounds the
corner with Daphne I assume the next
thing Velma says here is something about
how this curious accent never shows up
again for the rest of the movie there's
a ghost
I understand Shaggy and Scooby are
scaredy cats but they were literally
supposed to confront the ghost as part
of the plan Velma just referenced
doesn't matter how dumb the plan
actually is they're willing participants
Scooby and Shaggy survive this does this
barrel not have a lid on either end also
Matthew Lillard is six three and would
have nothing to hold on to in the barrel
so not only should his head be sticking
out of the top that barrel is defying
gravity by being up that high this is
the most fun and the most dangerous toy
factory in existence like who keeps a
fucking skateboard right next to heavy
machinery Oh should have a field day in
here this entire movie could be one
giant this works in so let's just go
ahead and give it five extra sins here
and yes this is supposed to be
essentially a live-action cartoon but
it's supposed to take place in the real
world so movie can't have its Scooby
Snacks and smoke them too let me get
this straight
this highly mobile ghost character has
at least five full seconds in the spa
and turns around twice to see and hear a
screaming barrel of dew headed right for
but does Jackson to move out of the way
also what was the ghost plant
he's been menacing a couple of times but
otherwise he's just been flying around
the factory with Daphne on his hip
the only way this movie could be more
2002 was if Mel Gibson Frankie Muniz and
that dude you're getting a Dell guy
we're walking with Pam here how could
you Pamela I am a lover boy of George
Clooney and proportions this is a kids
movie right because old man Smithers is
judge following up in this scene for a
group of people that dismiss the
supernatural on a daily basis they sure
have no issue with the fucking animal
being able to talk I whoa movie not only
did you blow your wad on that whole
monster reveal story and Pamela Anderson
you're now throwing a protagonist argue
for no reason before the climax of the
movie cliche
slow your roll man wait so where did the
rest of the crew go or several years
before uber and lyft and I doubt there's
a stream of cabs waiting around this
factory district shaggy couldn't have
offered them all right
this is one of the many references to
Scooby and Shaggy being high and having
the munchies all the time so considering
this fake out I assume they've switched
to edibles updating Fred's look to be
more 2002 Freddie Prinze jr. is
definitely the funniest part of this
movie you really get the sense that
sarah michelle gellar just kept all the
purple items from the wardrobe of the
cruel intention set I'm a black belt now
I've transformed my body into a
dangerous weapon Daphne the Vampire
Slayer
why does Scooby have to dress up in
kognito not only is he well known to the
world
a la Ted he's the one soul that the
villain needs at the end of the movie
what happens if he gets discovered by
the flight staff here nothing that's
what would you mind me taking a seat
there next to the fact that the
filmmakers went out and got talented
people like Isla Fisher and Matthew
Lillard is commendable but since they
stuck them in two thankless roles in a
scooby-doo movie say did I show I'm
pretty sure grandma wants to go back and
visit with their old pal Velma what kind
of freewheeling seat swinging airline is
this I know man to various owns the
plane but it's also supposed to be full
not subject to to seat changes in the
last three minutes any change man I want
a smoke you
I mean lick you I mean sports so did he
eat the kitty like did the movie
seriously just pan over to the start of
the island without any resolution on the
life of the cat or the ruse that got
Scooby on the plane I mean this is after
9/11 five media one colophon oh I can go
I guess it's in Rowan Atkinson's
contract for every movie that he must
have at least one mr. bean moment
casual assault battery in full view with
public is super casual and my heart
tattoo was drawn by a drunken
fourteen-year-old bassist from my
favorite black metal band oh you might
recognize him as the same person I
introduced him as the Velma has a raging
mystery boner right now why doesn't she
ask these kids what they're clearly
chanting she's already been questioning
folks no okay everyone's accepting that
scooby-doo can talk but how the fuck did
he learn to read I guess some of the CGI
here wasn't bad in 2002 but by relying
this much on it you're guaranteeing that
it's gonna look dated in a few years and
straight-up be a few years after that
lazy not shot jokes they're not just for
humans anymore what exactly is the theme
for spooky Island I'm not sure I
understand how a rabbit is spooky or has
anything to do with an island
shaggy not that I mind but they sure did
sex up these characters for this movie
like Daphne's dresses cut solo I can see
her hold xiphoid process there you go
there's plenty more where that came from
but is there that first looks like it
could fit two or three Scooby Snacks and
it max also why does definitely even
have Scooby Snacks as far as she knew
she was coming to this island alone
don't they want to keep people out of
the spooky castle if it's this easy to
get in here there should be at least 17
of those horned up college students up
here for each other nothing I was always
picked last for the teams geez I must
have forgotten how much teeny
melodramatic hyperbole there was in the
original scooby-doo series it's like a
medieval sizzler pretty sure at this
point the sizzler is like a medieval
sizzler
I'm a man of substance the dorky chicks
like you turn me on - that's racist
- are you telling me that this whole
house of horrors is controlled with one
switch and if it is why is everything
coming on at different times how would
they know where each character was why
isn't anyone from the party noticing
that big castle at the top of the hill
is suddenly extremely well lit I have so
many questions whoa is this actually
part of the ride why would they even
have the sausages do this and how would
they do it I don't know you kind of
track when they pull Scooby and Shaggy
back so mondo various just created
flying sausages and the insurance
premiums for this place have to have
been through the roof they had to have
been at least a couple deaths on the
books yeah just run through those sharp
things when they're slowly swinging out
of the way which should be like really
easy to do Daphne comes inches away from
death even though she could have just
dropped off the ride at any point before
now wait but what about the little
person that was standing right there
when Fred broke through the glass he
didn't even notice that asshole and if
so isn't that also racist god Fred sucks
luckily for the gang and our exposition
Fred hits a random button on this box
and it immediately starts playing the
training video from the very beginning
I'm up to snuff on all popular trends
word movie predicts the Brent Rambo
thumbs-up gift from many years later
wherever there's a brainwashing cult
there's always a power-hungry leader
behind it all the Papa Smurf figure so
the Smurfs are still a cartoon in a
world where mystery Inc is a real thing
what about Monchichi are you challenging
me yes yes he is
and a movie that's 79 minutes long and
has yet to introduce major character
scrappy-doo well now spend over a full
minute to indulge in a perk contest
we're here to solve a mystery yeah how
about the mystery of violent turned on
and tried to kill you a few minutes ago
anyone interested about why that
happened I got a plan
hmmm what's this yes I realize this
based on a cartoon that used to play
loose with physics and hallway doors but
the movie has set up a fairly realistic
universe therefore I thus degree that
this medieval switcheroo in this castle
is both a - called swell up and tummy
rub hi oh no the bad guys literally just
walked away how did they not hear
Shaggy's digestive issues ha ha ha yeah
we just discovered a potential death
cult and we're almost abducted by
seriously evil men that still control
this island and Daphne almost got
impaled and Fred almost sliced his
yarbles off let's not say take the
artifact back to the room and study it
let's make sure we do it in the most
public place possible so the bad guys
can catch Velma doing it I think this
describes a very old race of creatures
jeez Velma didn't you just meet this
dude I thought detectives were supposed
to keep things pretty fucking
confidential during an investigation
especially you know one where lots of
people could have their souls sucked out
of their bodies also I know Velma's
smart but she hasn't done any research
at this point so how would she know any
of this alright movie despite my
complaints I was with you up to this
point since it's an interesting concept
talented performers and a few decent
jokes but you just had to introduce the
most annoying character from the series
out of nowhere you moving you right in
the ear hole ah I see that Mary Jane
recently slipped into something more
this very same thing you've done since
you decided to clean your beans at dawn
not just Christmas party this joke must
have landed well for all the
seven-year-old Don Knotts fans in 2002
these assholes do this with every group
of kids that comes in
if so the contracting expenses would be
outrageous sure they survive this
because of the convenient ask tarp that
nobody knew about but there were no
injuries from the glass the frame the
bounce or the eventual landing well we
do have a unit in the vicinity can you
meet him at the pier this guy clearly
went to the shining school for people
who futile Ian lifelessly help people in
trouble in remote locations using CB
radio it's good Angela than everything
well then I doubt the scariest part of
this theme park is sugar ray yo-yo
impressively Freddie managed to sneak
this line into his wedding vows to Sarah
Michelle but then when I put on the ruse
of the beach party and the sugar ring
and the other if this is like invasion
of the Body Snatchers and all of them
are supposed to be poppy
besides movie magic bullsh how in the
ever-loving did both Scooby and Shaggy
jump through this door at an angle not
only would it be impossible to get up
enough speed in that tiny Shack there
was no ramp at the door Shaggy and c3po
are clearly in competition for the worst
forced movie puns even though Scooby's
been speaking in almost perfect English
this entire movie we must have this
blatant miscommunication for the end of
the movie to come about I mean does it
really fucking matter with knowing her
identity really affect the outcome here
return to my body and how does Velma
know this will work she's an expert on
protoplasm leaving a body now - also the
thing that's seriously a bowl of actual
souls look the most fun parts about
Scooby Doo episodes back in the day
we're finding out a who did it and B how
they did it and it was almost always
some sort of non supernatural technical
method sure they yadi added some stuff
but most of it made sense and the point
was that mystery Inc used their brains
to solve the mystery this salt swamp a
demon army bolt is not just ruining this
movie it's ruining my childhood memories
dammit
ok I'm almost certain the only reason
they decided to put a new soul into
Velma's body was to somehow justify this
low-cut revision to her classic sweater
just as we could see more of her
carnally knees acne you okay yeah but
I'm not Daphne ah just what this mystery
phantasmagorical drunk needed body
switch humor hey I can look at myself
naked and the first thing that comes to
mind for Fred is to immediately sexually
assault his close friend and colleagues
body again
Fred's blaming they can't do the ritual
without a pure human soul I didn't say
human okay look I love dogs
and this is kind of like an emotional
scene but also is scooby Doo necessarily
pure of soul like he's a good dog and
all but he definitely smokes a lot of
drugs is indulgent and occasionally an
asshole like when he tried to fight
Shaggy a few minutes ago
I'm not saying he's definitely not
worthy I'm just wondering if he was the
best horse or dog to bet the entire dark
pocalypse on so I'm gonna do what I
always do I'm gonna eat my Selma Scooby
Snack but I'm gonna say my best pal is
that what you always do those shanks
seems to me it's more like I'm gonna try
and save Scooby get up but within the up
will miraculously save ourselves you
think I'm gonna fall for that trying to
make me feel like part of the game dude
everyone in this gang has their own
thing
Scooby and Shaggy are this
Daphne's the good-looking but trying too
hard one thread is the conceded leader
that's not too bright and you're the
smart one given your one well in this
movie three character traits how did you
not figure this out
let's get kinky with holy I think I
sighed so loud that I broke my xiphoid
process did everyone on the island go
like isn't everyone else at demon now
but they're not hanging out at the most
populous place on the beach in the hopes
they'll run into a few people who could
stop their plan for dominance Jesus in
Christ they've had time to set up an
entire pulley system couldn't Shaggy
have already done this when he was
releasing Fred Velma and Daphne's heads
it could have just released everyone
else's and all the monsters would have
been vanquished by sunlight and everyone
would have been saved I get that they're
trying to butter Scooby up for this
sacrifice but all the minions supposed
to be soulless assholes with limited
vocabulary this movie is unnecessarily
complicated I'm really sorry I haven't
been a very good friend since we got
here but listen to me bro you gotta
trust me now the speech must be so
convincing that it embolden all the
other people carrying the shrine to
ignore it most of whom are less than 6
inches away and well within earshot only
that asshole just stole Scooby fucking
do soul this movie in all the ways that
who the daemon righteous
I shall absorb the energy soul man this
ending sure does feel Suicide Squad II
doesn't it all it needs is a fire God
and for Will Smith to say something
extremely sexist look a man in a mask
Fred sees a small cut then immediately
decides to tear this mother for his
entire face off
Jesus this movie is dark power sure if
there was something in this movie that
we didn't get enough of it was the
ability of scrappy-doo to be super
annoying I have a strong feeling that if
you mix this movie a certain way it
could end up as legit porno The Matrix
is a good movie but seriously the matrix
were ruining the majority of fight
scenes for the next 10 plus years wow
this is the biggest character switch
isla Fisher will play until she tells
Vince Vaughn that she's actually not a
virgin in wedding crashers so this whole
Daphne getting captured is just
worldwide knowledge are the mystery ink
antics covered on Telemundo so the plan
just accidentally late they set up a
good trap to make this happen but
everything went wrong
from the pulley system being broke to
Daphne pretty much getting lost and her
ass kicked above ground but hey kids
movie from 2002
right yeah not my soul isn't stolen in
this literal hell ho I'm gonna party the
kind of a party tonight Spring Break and
this is how we got Sarah Michelle Prince
3 also there was zero romantic tension
built up between these two for the
entire film but movies got a movie I
guess I'm not doing okay just for the
sake of nostalgia and the level of fawn
Matthew Lillard puts into these shaggy
performances I'll take us in off but
seriously this movie
through the combined intuitive powers
mystery Inc we've discovered that the
real villain behind this mystery is in
fact scrappy Cornelius do but also the
ability to remove Souls right like isn't
that the main issue here that there's an
ability to separate the soul from its
human host you lead with that there's
nobody I'd rather gorge myself with then
you scooby-doo Oh terrific not only did
we get a post-credits sequence in this
stupid-ass movie it's an exact replica
of that restaurant scene from Dumb &
Dumber
we're not gonna do it you can put it
anywhere I'm gonna get to work
translating these inscriptions that
Daphne found
I'll go research cults on the net with
that girl from the bus
[Music]
so ready to take it to the next level -
you want to watch me with a girl what
about those Brazilian I touch them
[Music]
maniacal laugh whatever the case
wherever there is injustice
you will find us